Chillen im Pool
für die Wissenschaft.
Ihr braucht nicht unbedingt einen
Pool, eine Badewanne tut es auch,
um das zu beobachten:
schrumpelige Finger und Zehen.
Wie kommt das Schrumpeln
zu Stande und wozu ist es gut?
Es fällt auf, dass nur die Haut
an den Fingern und Zehen schrumpelt,
am Rest des Körpers nicht.
Allgemein ist die Haut
an den Händen und Füßen
anders als am Rest des Körpers.
Sie ist dicker,
es wachsen keine Härchen
und sie hat die höchste Dichte
an Berührungsrezeptoren.
Lange dachte man, dass sich
die Haut mit Wasser vollsaugt.
Doch ganz so einfach ist es nicht.
Wenn das Schrumpeln
nur durchs Aufsaugen kommen würde,
wäre die "Osmose" daran schuld.
Die Salzkonzentration in meinem
Körper ist höher als die im Pool.
Man sagt auch: Der Osmotische Druck
in meinem Körper ist höher
als der im Pool.
Ein Druckunterschied
möchte immer ausgeglichen werden.
Dazu gibt es 2 Möglichkeiten:
Entweder das Salz aus
meinem Körper wandert in den Pool.
Doch das lässt meine Haut nicht zu.
Oder das Wasser aus dem Pool
wandert in meinen Körper.
Deswegen ist der Effekt
auch viel geringer,
wenn man im Meer baden geht,
weil bei Salzwasser
der Osmotische Druck viel höher ist.
Dasselbe gilt auch
für Pools mit viel Chlor.
Am besten könnt ihr den Effekt
in der Badewanne beobachten.
Doch die Theorie
mit dem Osmotische Druck
ist höchstens die halbe Wahrheit,
sagen Neurologen.
Menschen, bei denen
die Nerven beschädigt sind,
können so lange im Wasser liegen,
wie sie wollen,
ohne dass die Finger
schrumpelig werden.
Neurologen sind davon überzeugt,
dass das Schrumpeln
weniger ein passives Aufquellen,
sondern mehr eine aktive Reaktion
des Nervensystems ist.
Bei längerem Wasser-Kontakt
sorgt das
"Sympathische Nervensystem" dafür,
dass sich winzige Blutgefäße in den
Fingern und den Zehen zusammenziehen
und so
für den Schrumpel-Effekt sorgen.
Aber wozu das Ganze?
Englische Forscher fanden heraus,
dass man mit schrumpeligen Fingern
glatte Objekte im Wasser
besser greifen kann.
Die Rillen
wirken wie Profile beim Reifen.
Wozu jetzt
aber schrumpelige Zehen gut sind,
das gilt es herauszufinden.
Habt ihr eine Idee?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Schönschlau.
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Damit ist unser wunderschöner
Italien-Urlaub fast vorbei.
Wollt ihr Eindrücke davon haben,
schaut ins letzte Video.
Nächste Woche gehts weiter im
schönen Deutschland. Bleibt sicher.